.
AND PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE ENDED
IT.
OUR NEXT GUEST SHOT BIN LADEN IN
THE FACE.
JOINING ME NOW IS NAVY SEAL ROB
O'NEIL.
ROB, 20 YEARS, A LOT OF
THOUGHTS, A LOT OF EXPERIENCES,
PEOPLE KNOW YOU FROM THE BIN
LADEN RAID BUT YOU HAVE SPENT
MULTIPLE TOURS OVER MANY YEARS
IN AFGHANISTAN.
AM I OFF BASE HERE?
>> I THINK YOU ARE COMPLETELY ON
BASE, PETE.
AND THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
YEAH, IT'S ONE OF THOSE PLACES
AFGHANISTAN WHERE IF YOU HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE, YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE
PEOPLE.
ONE OF THE BEST STORIES THAT I
HAVE IS ONE OF MY INTERPRETERS
WAS ALSO MY CHEF.
I GOT IN AN ARGUMENT WITH HIM
ONE TIME I SAID YOU KNOW IF WE
SURROUND AFGHANISTAN WITH
300-FOOT WALL THAT WAS
ELECTRIFIED, YOU WOULDN'T HAVE A
TELEVISION IN 10,000 YEARS.
MY COUNTRY PUT A MAN ON THE MOON
IN 200 YEARS AND HE SAID
MR. CAN'T PUT A MAN ON THE MOON
IT'S THIS BIG.
AND THAT'S -- I MEAN, SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE, NOT ONLY DO THEY
NOT KNOW HOW OLD THEY ARE, THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME IS.
IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD.
I HAVE SEEN TRUE POVERTY THAT
CHILDREN WITH NO CLOTHES PLAYING
IN SEWAGE.
IT'S UP IS DOWN AND DOWN IS UP.
WE CAN NEVER INSTALL
JEFFERSONIAN DEMOCRACY THERE
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
ONE OF THE BEST QUOTES I HAVE
EVER HEARD WE HAVE THE WATCHES
BUT THEY HAVE THE TIME.
>> Pete: THAT'S NOT TO DISPARAGE
AFGHANS.
WE HAVE MET WONDERFUL PEOPLE
OVER THERE.
WE GET IT IT'S THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE MOON TO YOUR POINT.
IT'S AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
WORLD.
WE TRIED TO BUILD A TOP DOWN
AFGHAN ARMY.
I'M SURE YOU WOULD HAVE MET THE
BEST TRAINED AFGHANS.
THERE WILL BE ONES THAT WILL
STAY TO FIGHT.
BUT, ULTIMATELY, WAS YOUR
EXPERIENCE THAT THOSE WITH THE
AFGHAN NATIONAL ARMY IF THE
TALIBAN IS WINNING, THEY ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO THAT SIDE.
>> IT IS SUCH A DIFFICULT PLACE
TO BE THAT A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
AND, AGAIN, SOME OF THE BEST
PEOPLE I HAVE EVER MET IN MY
LIFE WERE AFGHANIS.
SOME OF THE BEST PEOPLE EVER.
THEY HAVE ALLI IF YOU ASK FOR
HELP THEY WILL GIVE IT TO YOU.
THEY'RE ALSO FIGHTING FOR MONEY.
HAQQANI NETWORK PAYS, TALIBAN
PAYS, WE PAY.
THEY DON'T WANT A PROPPED UP
PROXY GOVERNMENT.
THEY WANT SOMETHING THAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE AND THAT'S WHAT THE
TALIBAN IS.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME BACK.
IN IT SEEMS LIKE YESTERDAY WE
ARE WATCHING PEOPLE SHAVE THEIR
BEARDS AND 20 YEARS AGO THEY'RE
COMING BACK.
>> Pete: ROB, REAL QUICK, WE ARE
OUT OF TIME.
WHEN SHOULD WE HAVE LEFT
DECLARED VICTORY.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN OUT
THEREOF IN 2003.
I WAS THERE IN 2005.
THAT'S WHEN WE RESCUED THE LONE
SURVIVOR MARK LUTTRELL.
THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN CITIES AND VALLEYS.
THEY WANT THEIR VALLEYS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT.
AGAIN, THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TIME
IS.
WE SHOULD ARE BEEN OUT.
KEPT AIR BASES LIKE BAGRAM AND
CROSS BORDER CAN.
>> Pete: MAYBE AFTER BIN LADEN
WAS KILLED AS WELL.